the flat war sheltering in this camp
for the internally displaced in idlib
syria's rebels
last stronghold now they are at the
mercy of storms
and floods abu muhammad has taken his
family to higher ground
after the rainstorms turned the camp
into a muddy quagmire
a charity gave us a tent which won't be
easy to erect
and then i have to bring all our
belongings to this new site which is
quite frankly
a hustle in a harsh winter people here
are confronting the floods and cold
temperatures
with makeshift stoves of burning rubbish
to stay
warm on the outskirts of aleppo
families are desperate frustrated that
the repeated calls for help
seem to be ignored look at me
i'm 80 years old my wife is paralyzed
and my two children have special needs
i'm praying to god for mercy tarantula
reigns
have compounded the misery of ahmed and
his wife
my children are disabled i can't carry
them
one of them needs a hundred dollars
worth of medication every month
but we can't afford that amount of money
camp settlements
spread across the border with turkey
when syrian government troops backed by
russian warplanes
launched a major offensive last year the
aim was to recapture the rebel
strongholds of
idlib and aleppo the u.n
limited humanitarian deliveries to the
region
to just one crossing point from turkey
a year later the same people are
struggling with the cold and rains
forced from their homes millions have
been on the move
since the start of the conflict ten
years ago
many say they've lost hope of peace and
their return home
alba al-jazeera